Creek honey ah what the hell
sorry I just had a knight named what a
knight means something you swear you're
never gonna do again but then it works
its way to your subconscious oh it keeps
popping up
don't you mean nightmare no that's yet
to come
you
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to once
upon a time there was an awesome movie
called Jurassic world and a gate bird to
a shitty sequel call the law school
thanks oh and I liked it birth to the
lost cause Jurassic Park 3
this is the one that many people
consider to be the absolute worst of the
series but is it really the worst I mean
don't get me wrong it's a bad movie it's
a complete waste of time but in a
strange way it kind of knows it's a
waste of time so it doesn't even try to
be anything big and massive like its
predecessors on the one hand it's kind
of refreshing as it's only an hour and a
half long instead of two and a half
hours and most of the time has focused
on the dinosaur chases and not annoying
characters well I said most but does
that mean the movie should be hated more
or less it's kind of like punishing a
child for doing nothing wrong but the
punishment is so ridiculously lenient
that it's obvious the child isn't going
to learn his lesson
what's more tragic that child wrongfully
being punished or the parent not giving
a crap if the punishments effective
let's finish off this trilogy 60 million
years in the suck this is Jurassic Park
3 it begins with a kid paragliding with
some tour guides along the island from
the second film that's apparently
restricted and in case that wasn't clear
for all the kindergarteners this movie
was made for thing why didn't big
cartoon letters to clarify thank you why
don't you just spell that a little bit
more in case we're too fucking stupid to
follow
so yeah the movies pretty much
emphasizing you'd have to be a goddamn
idiot to go here so we see some goddamn
idiots who decide to go here make sure
you get close as you can
I'm not so close that you don't want to
be two-timing come on they know they're
taking a kid into a restricted area
filled with fucking dinosaurs what could
possibly go yeah after the dinosaurs eat
the boat the kid and the other guy
obviously they're just to get eaten cut
loose and get blown onto the island this
leads us to dr. grant a man who says he
has no interest in returning to Jurassic
Park unless he's paid a shit ton of
money he's played by Sam Neill a man who
says he has no interest in returning to
Jurassic Park unless he's paid a shit
ton of money hey cam Vulcan casting my
other things he's a paleontologist
hey we say what absolutely nobody wanted
to see dr. Grandon dr. Sattler
completely split up as she decided to
have a family with someone else oh yeah
you nailed that one movie that's exactly
what everybody was hoping was going to
happen by the end of the first film just
like Tommy Lee Jones splitting up with
his wife and men in black 2 or the
orphanage being shut down and Blues
Brothers 2000 role the supporting
characters being killed in alien 3 you
made one of the most likable elements in
the previous film mean completely
nothing why don't you just write a big
sign at the ending of the first movie
saying you don't like this you don't
want to see this go anywhere do not
focus on the heartwarming moment where
intentionally focusing on oh shit so you
know Mark's been working for the State
Department now yeah what do you do mark
yes what do you do aside from pumping
out children for my baby obsessed former
girlfriend so what are you working on
now raptors mostly my favorite even
stranger thing is they still have
chemistry when they talk I want to see
them together I want to see them figure
out dinosaur shit
we found what looks like a very
sophisticated resonating chamber wait a
second so we were right I mean they had
the ability to vocalize but nope
his girlfriend this movie is replaced by
this guy Billy played by caster Troy's
brother from faceoff and this time
instead of focusing on swapping faces
he's focusing on swapping rector voices
as get this they recreate a raptor
volkl chamber so they can flawlessly
recreate a raptors call listen to this
yeah I'm sure that's how it works
hey look I have the Volkl chambers of
Keanu Reeves whoa oh yes somebody put me
in a good movie but it comes too late as
dr. grant has to go from fundraiser to
fundraiser to try and raise money to
continue his digging work does anyone
have a question does anyone have a
question that does not relate to
Jurassic Park hey it's like the wheel
same deal the comic convention isn't all
this conjecture kind of moot once the UN
in Costa Rica and everyone decides how
to handle that second island John
Hammond did a Jurassic Park is create
genetically engineered theme park
monsters you wouldn't want to get on to
Isla Sorna and study them if you have
the chance no force on earth or heaven
could get me on that island that's right
no force on heaven or earth could
possibly get him on that island except
for the exact same thing that got him
there the first one I could write all
kinds of numbers on this check dr. Gramm
this expedition is run by pol pussy and
Amanda pussy played by Wayne H Maci and
Taylor Leone who tell dr. grant they
want to explore Iola sequel on a plane
for their anniversary and because this
movie is just eager to get itself over
with he blindly agrees but he can't help
but feel something terrible lies in the
future and that was our first big scare
everybody a prehistoric version of the
Muppet Show fucking you fail I'm sorry I
don't care at what strategic point you
put it or in what area you have it pop
out there is no way a dinosaur saying
how is ever going to be scary Alan no I
told you it's not gonna work
Alan no I told you it's not happening
Alan that's it I'm out of here
Alan you piss off
hey critic I've got this pain in my
stomach could you check it out yeah sure
Alan damnit we can lost Alan hello hello
is this nostalgia critic yeah this is
the st. Joseph's Hospital I regret to
inform you that your mother has just
passed away
what yes she died last night peacefully
in her sleep
god I I didn't know she was sick she
wanted to keep her from you she knew how
busy you were and didn't want to
interrupt your work
hey sweet Jesus she fought hard she put
up a good fight but in the end there's
something nothing we can do
I'm sorry son what did she leave any
final words as a matter of fact she did
well what were they it was one single
solitary word well what was it please
all right
are you listening yeah are you listening
listening are you listening
yeah all right here is a final word Alan
I hate this dare whoo
I got got
and if you look down below you'll see
the lift over animation from the way up
before times six oh I mean uh
don't they look real Wow we have a
landing strip up ahead you want me to
put it out and set it up you can't land
here with us however when they look for
a place to land dr. grant urges them not
to but gets knocked out when he wakes up
he finds out that the whole point of
this journey wasn't to just go
sightseeing but to bring back their son
who got lost while paragliding they also
have little to no money are currently
divorced and really enjoy annoyingly
shouting their son's name do you think
this island is the police office from
home alone I don't think you can just
randomly find someone by shouting across
the Rope we tell your wife to stop
making that noise that is a very very
bad idea
dr. grant said that's a bad idea what
the bad idea
what was that Georgia the jungle what do
you think so as our team is clearly
wondering why the hell they didn't bring
a helicopter seeing how they don't need
a runway the plane is knocked over by
something obviously hungry for extras oh
please let this be one of those monster
movies where the black guy doesn't get
dammit
it's okay just use the bullhorn to call
the police all right you guys go ahead
I'm gonna keep looking for you in here
oh hey I see what you did there
but sure enough who makes another
appearance
go in there teach that squiggly John
fish
yeah
no no no they just happen then it just
happened those motherfucking grx nobody
else does the motherfucking t-rex who's
this bitch that think she's the
motherfucking tearing she's not the
motherfucking t-rex in the poster for
transformers 4 the splurging of the dog
that's not a dinosaur that looks like
Daffy duck's beak after a cat shot it's
the motherfucking t-rex it's like
killing off Batman replacing with
SuperDuper better man no no this is some
things you do not fuck around with it's
like taking a kid's favorite toy and
being like hey there kiddo
you like your Dora the explora doll sure
do well what would you think if I catch
you a brand new Barbie doll oh that's ok
I love Dora know you love Barbie oh I'm
pretty sure I love Dora
yeah look at that bar be killed or now
you have to love Barbie oh you don't
care nothing for her you instead love
your mommy now
Wow how's that dark place when I wrote
that what why do you expect
can you really fucking blame me after
seeing the motherfucking t-rex be I I I
need a break
here's a donation site to give money to
the greatest dinosaur who ever existed
you
but for the t-rex is killed by the
who-cares asaurus dr. grant lets out his
frustration on mr. and mrs. pussy please
please don't stop please and as is
typical with every tale Leone
performance Willy Wonka feigning
interest still comes off as more
convincing please please don't stop
please stop don't come back the whole
movie she's like a robot who's trying to
figure out this human thing called
emotion because we have permission to
fly low you're not gonna look for dr.
grave you drive five miles under the
speed limit ball I shot this thorn he
disappeared if he'd been with you we'd
be completely safe we even have two
seats reserved on the first commercial
flight to the moon I find it extremely
difficult to predict which you will find
acceptable perhaps hunger will compel
you to try it again it also doesn't help
that she breezed through her mouth more
than Kristen Stewart does look at this
scene she doesn't say a line conveying
emotion or anything it just holds on her
fucking leaving her mouth open it's
really kind of baffling see from here
hmm by a pretty big fucking amount of
luck they find the kids parachute as
well as Beth the guy who was paragliding
with him or at least what's left of him
you know I didn't think it was possible
to out Capshaw Kate Capshaw but lady you
are seriously cutting off the nuts of my
patient I'm gonna go start an ad on
standby movie to make his acting well
good you're back mr. Kirby thought
they'd come across not the safest of
environments I hate these games things
don't get any better when they come
across a research lab where the worst
kind of Raptor is waiting the Mohawk
Raptor dude that just want me the
drummer for blink 182 I'm intrigued by
this thing I said I'd never be intrigued
by in the opening so the left is let out
the call of darth vader with mucus
buildup as everyone gets to safety
except grant
Oh No maybe we should have actually
eaten him instead of looking at him for
a couple seconds just wanted another one
to say clever girl Joey I'm sorry it was
just so cool when he said it I just
wanted to hear something update again
you are so insecure Julie you shut up
thank God Princess Mononoke comes in to
save the day which turns out to be Eric
Vaughn plot point when in djenne cleared
out they left a lot of stuff behind any
weapons no no just use the last of the
gas grenades Eric I had to tell you I'm
astonished that you've lasted eight
weeks on this island so that all's been
okay I'm all for strong kid characters
contributing more to story aside from
being a helpless wave but any weeds on
his fucking own on a goddamn Island
filled with Dinosaurs
this is t-rex pee how'd you get it you
don't want to know
why the hell didn't we even evil ask you
this kids we could just drop a bunch of
paper clips and a balloon and he'd have
an army style wrapped in a millisecond
they shouldn't be saving that kid he
should be saving them did you read
Malcolm's book it was kind of preachy
and too much chaos everything's chaos
seemed like the guy was kind of high in
himself bad and he included all his arms
who does that
but when looking for one another they
hear a phone ring and conclude that it
must be the other group
I knew it however strangely enough
neither of them seemed to have the phone
I don't have it I loaned it to Nash he
must have had it when he
you have a voicemail boys strange how
they could hear the ring of a tiny phone
and yet the giant clomping sounds of a
monster even bigger than the t-rex who
shook the ground whenever she walked for
some reason didn't catch their ears
yes obviously if she could crash through
a giant spike filled gate surely a small
steel door would be too much for her I'm
sure she shares in the same pain as the
aliens from science but we do discover
why the Raptors have been pursuing them
as long as they were Billy a fucking
expert on dinosaurs thought stealing a
few eggs wouldn't piss them off at all I
took him on an impulse I thought they'd
be worth a fortune enough to fund it
excite another 10 more years but I did
it with the best intentions some of the
worst things imaginable have been done
with the best intentions just look at
every Academy Awards Show so he decides
there's only one thing to do with the
eggs destroy it
what the catches with him
what if they catch us without I thought
we agreed we do not negotiate with
Raptors so Indiana Schmo tries to leave
them out safely but guess what the fun
they come across more dinosaurs God
Teri's never been the same since they
canceled pee-wee's Playhouse will you
come a fogger to play with me you go
outside and play with me
huh I guess the mother wants the kids to
work for their food I know whatever I
see the baby I put the food at least
five feet away from it lazy bastard
should work for their own damn grub
of course he Maja's to pack the
parachute perfectly eat despite of being
ripped up by a tree and then just to
save the kid Carrie I told you not to
play Acapulco cliff diver in the
playoffs Terry what's the matter with
you that's the freshest water but saline
seems like he's not able to save himself
despite the loss of their wingman they
still managed to throw in a few seconds
of oh yeah dinosaurs are magical and
shit
and I mean literally a few seconds
thirty seven to be exact
37 yeah 37 this whole movie is like a
Jurassic Park paint-by-numbers there's
no flow or segue it's just hitting the
points you know you need to hit hit the
filled up at the big Dino moment hit the
little Dino moment hit the raw moment
except in that oh and a moment not only
is it incredibly short but the dinosaurs
aren't even that whimsical looking they
look creepy as fucking shit they look
like purple sores crossed with that new
faceless Joker
this isn't charming it's scary as hell
well thankfully they come across one of
the intentionally scary ones though this
ought to get a few thrills at least okay
I think I figured out the problem here
all the dinosaurs are supposed to be
really threatening or either laughably
useless or distractingly cute and all
the divers are supposed to be harmless
or terrifyingly frightening or
horrendously hideous
I think someone in the design department
got a few notes backwards oh it's time
to paint number up Liggett Ori rain
scene with monster in it as Flintstone
asuras attacks yet again
what is this dinosaurs deal with these
guys it's not like there isn't bigger
game to chase help the fucking t-rex
probably would have fed her for a month
so why does she keep going after them
maybe two dinosaurs all people look like
running middle fingers hey makes about
as much sense as any other reason but
grand finally manages to get that cell
phone to work so who does he call the
police the army the Navy okay take your
phone to mama now unfortunately the kid
gets distracted by the irony Channel
they have to fight the Dino off
themselves well to be fair that was
scarier than most of the other dinosaurs
on this movie but they managed to swim
their way out just in time to paint
number action breakup dialogue oh it
doesn't matter what it is they talk
about it could be anything
really fucking anything just to make
people think they're not watching
anything but mindless action when
clearly that's exactly what they're
doing
come on just a solid minute of filler
remember when we went fishing a couple
of summers ago was putting the boat in
the water and the trailer sank the tow
truck tried to pull us out and he got
dragged into a truck driver wanted to
knock my lights out I'm miss fishing or
ten fucking seconds we'll apparently do
do wow that must've been like a record
possibly the fastest pointless exchange
ever in an action movie but like I said
nobody cares about getting invested this
time around just show us what toys you
want us to buy and we'll be good
ah here we
okay these are built up as like the
greatest hunters why do they always just
look at them instead of attacking them
and or getting their eggs back was this
some kind of power trip for them well
well what do we get is Wiggy took a
couple of dweeb owes that don't need
their luncheon would be ashamed is
something warrants to happens did them
sit at squid suit in but of course grant
manages to communicate with them via
bullshit horn the translation might have
gotten a little jumbled
they manage of course to get away and
come across a scene from lost as it
turns out settler coal the right people
to save the day
thank God we dropped off that guy in the
suit totally alone ahead of time or else
you'd be less likely to commit that
visual to memory okay hold on so a
scientist who's not very rich or famous
gets help to go after another scientist
who's not very rich or famous and gets
the fucking army but when a little kid
who would obviously make headlines if he
showed up dead is in trouble what do we
get ah bullshit bullshit even Billy
seems to have somehow made it out okay
I don't know the movie doesn't cater
explain it why should we care to hear it
until it seems the adventure is not
quite over what the hell is that
I don't know maybe just looking for new
nesting grounds it's all new world map
let's go home except for the fact that
it is over well the flying fuck was the
point of that oh good the things that
try to peck our dicks off are looking
for a new nesting ground who pity
fucking do why is this worth mentioning
hell are you even trying to make it look
like a good thing
killer dinosaurs can take flight and are
flying towards your homes
what's with the wind z music this is
horrifying news
yes my dear fifl there is still so much
America left we yes - we will make their
insides the outside oh and that's
Jurassic Park 3 is it the worst of the
series kinda sorta but it is mercifully
short and only an hour and a half the
film plays more like a b-movie just
bring in who you like get him into
action quickly and then have them leave
just as quickly
well what's world was technically a
bigger film it was so long and so heavy
and with its message and blank
characters that I remember it being more
painful to sit through here the movie
kind of knows it has no reason to exist
so it just sort of comes and goes it's
obvious less effort is put into it so
it's kind of hard to get truly that
angry with it it comes off as less of an
insult and more something that obviously
is just pointless in its existence I
guess in the long run it's a personal
preference which one is the worst but
one thing is definitely for sure that is
one big pile of shit no that's what I'm
going to take on this movie because not
only does it deserve it but it would
also make it at least a little bit more
interesting i'm enes Tasha Critic I
remember so you don't have to Alan
Eric